well I worry that over the past few
weeks the government has looked like
libertarian jihadists and and treated
the whole country as a kind of
laboratory mice in which to carry out
kind of ultra Ultra free market
experiments and this is not where the
where the country is there's been one
Horror Story a story after another it's
not just about tax cuts for the rich but
about benefit Cuts cuts to Public
Services even today we're reading that
they may impose charges on long-term
sick and disabled for who are parking at
hospitals and this is not what the what
the public wants and I really believe
that the prime minister
given everything that has gone on needs
to set out do I do a fireside chat to
the British people apologize for what
has gone on and set out a vision for
compassionate conservatism with social
justice at its heart
so you think the Prime Minister needs to
apologize personally
do you know um yesterday in my
constituency one person after another
expressed a dismay but
um one or two people actually said to me
that they were frightened
frightened about everything that had
gone on worried about their payments
worried about their mortgages what about
their a small small business and I don't
want a government where where people
come up to me in the street and saying
they're frightened about this isn't
about the opinion polls this is about
we're in danger of creating a after the
covert pandemic an economic pandemic
unless things aren't sorted out uh
really really soon we you know the
country wants affordable housing they
need a public spending to be maintained
on essential services like my area of
education for example they want tax cuts
but focused on the lower paid and those
who are struggling the most the the
government should recast the energy
package which whilst I welcomed it of
course it was a huge intervention it
should be focused predominantly on the
poor and those who are wealthy and big
business should not be getting a rebates
as currently set out
and you're obviously someone who's
always you know as we said in the
introduction you know championed uh the
values of blue collar workers you know
not the super rich people who work hard
to earn you know a moderate salary
people like places like Harley where you
represent do they think that the prime
minister is on their side or do you
think what has happened is effectively
playing into people's concerns that the
conservatives always just look after the
rich
well the awful stereotypes of
conservatives in the past that we were
just the party for the well-off and the
rich the government over the past few
weeks have played into that stereotype
every day of the week and as I say said
to you the biggest problem for me is not
that my constituents are angry at the
government but some of them are actually
frightened because they fear for what
has has gone on and this can't can't
continue and I welcome what uh Jeremy
Hunt was saying uh yesterday in the
media
um but the proof of the pudding will be
in the me in the eating they have to be
dramatic improvements and pretty quickly
you say you welcome some of what the new
Chancellor said but Jeremy Hunt also
said that spending needs to be looked at
efficiencies need to be found you or
someone who's always talked about the
values of Public Services particularly
of course in education where you have a
a particular interest are you concerned
that we might be seeing a return to
austerity
well to be fair when we had austerity
under George Osborn and David Cameron
they managed to protect some of the core
budgets they cut taxes for lower earners
they introduce the living wage they
created millions of apprenticeships they
reformed our welfare they were able to
do all this even though there was
austerity because they got the deficit
under control so it can be done of
course they have to be efficiencies but
we absolutely cannot cut public services
in the core areas I mean just to look at
education over between 2010 and 2025 it
will only have had a three percent
increase in real in real terms our kids
have suffered massively because of
school closures during lockdown there
has to be more investment in education
and if the government is saying they can
increase defense spending they can
hardly say well no we haven't got any
money for a essential services is like
funding our schools and colleges
properly
now we're talking about the new
Chancellor here there are reports in the
papers this morning that number 10
originally approached Sergey Javit to
see if he would be interested in being
Chancellor now he's one of your closest
allies in the House of Commons you went
to University together your friends
there you helped run his leadership
campaign is it true that he was sounded
out for that job
I have no idea I'm not going to party to
those discussions they're way above my
pay grade but I'm just made to read in
the newspapers the briefings that have
come out using four-letter words to
describe Sajid Javid I've known him as
you say since University is a really
good man he was respected he didn't tank
the economy when he was a Chancellor and
if the Prime Minister wants to unite the
party and get people around her then
these kind of negative briefings about
colleagues have got to have got to stop
I just want to read the quote that you
allude to there just so people know what
we're talking about I am going to edit
my language because it is Sunday morning
this is a Sunday Times quote from a
number 10 source and when it was put to
the Prime Minister that she decided
sounded outside a jabard the Prime
Minister laughed out loud at the
suggestion she sat in the cabinet with
jabard for 10 years and she knows who is
good and who is
the four letter word that you're
referring to is that briefing helpful
it's disgusting as such a Javid is a
respected and good and decent uh man
he's had a number of offices a secretary
of state and just to call colleagues
four letter words all it does is uh
bring this harmony to the party when
what the Prime Minister should be doing
is doing everything possible to bring
people together bring the country uh
country together it's just absolutely
unnecessary and uncalled for
or do you think it sounds about the
current number 10 operation
well if they're doing things like this
and given the events of the last few
weeks clearly there have to be how to be
changes
um but it you know at the end of the day
this is about the government you you
they've uh they've got rid of one uh
Chancellor
um the the Prime Minister needs to
absolutely as I say say sorry to the
British people set out a vision of
compassionate conservatism support
workers conservatism as every prime
minister has done since 2010 including
Boris Johnson when he launched the
leveling up uh program and unify unify
the party
now I want to ask this question
um because you in some ways are at the
sharp end what the appalling polls the
concept of the party really mean you
know you represent Harlow uh it's always
been a bit of a Bellwether seat you took
it in 2010 you've been kind of
consolidating uh conservative support in
that seat ever since you know if you
look at the current polls it's game over
for the conservatives and places like
Harlow isn't it
well and you look at all the polling
done by Matthew Goodwin who's you know
not from the left very respected has
been advising Tori Prime Ministers and
toy senior toy party members for a long
time he's shown that in the so-called
red wall seats and working class seats
like mine in Harlow that we are
hemorrhaging in the in the polls and
that's what I was trying to say to the
Prime Minister the public want a
compassionate conservative government
they're not asking for libertarianism
they want fairness they want us spending
on essential Public Services they all do
want sell money as well and I mentioned
that during the Cameron years the
government were able to do to actually
do both and that's why things need to
change and pretty quickly
do things need to change at the top do
you think Liz truss should lead the
conservatives into the next election
well at this time I'm not calling for
the prime minister to go I worry about
further political instability but even
more economic instability but things
have to improve I I think she needs to
set out some of the things that I've
been suggesting the government as a
whole need to show that they are a
compassionate conservative government
because if things don't uh change then
maybe you know the thing I just think
that perhaps things may not be able to
carry on in the way that they have been
when they're talking the papers about
MPS looking to install a Unity candidate
to replace her which is sunak Ben
Wallace Penny Morden all names mentioned
are those conversations seriously
happening
well of course
um colleagues are are unhappy with what
is going on we've hemorrhaged in the
opinion polls the public just can't
understand what has happened you know as
I said many of them are frightened about
their their Futures and their the cost
of of living it's inevitable that
colleagues are just uh we're all talking
to see what can be what can be done
about it and that's what I hope very
much in the next few days the government
has a dramatic reset apologizes for what
has gone on and and becomes the
concerted compassionate government that
the public voted for in 2019 and
implements the conservative Manifesto
that the public voted for in 2019. are
you talking there about the next few
days I mean is that the kind of time
frame that we're really talking about
for the prime minister to do something
differently and turn things around in
your view
it's got to be a dramatic change and
pretty quickly and to stabilize the
economy to reassure the uh the public
and to reset the government